welcome to this video playing the Dark
Passenger Dark Passenger nope no name
yeah what we get three I could play the
exchange why not I never play that it's
not really bad hmm ok now here I don't
know much at all yeah I can basically
never take on g4 yeah do i get f 4
played interesting a 92 c form and I
don't know it what's this good god is it
displayed differently I don't know the
theory Bishop g4 the line that I never
looked at as black and this is why I
have absolutely no idea okay I don't
really know how this is played we can go
look she won trying to provoke some some
weakness here like g6 how is he going 96
96 m
hmm I have no player idea disposition
what to do maybe I can reroute the night
somewhere g32 f5 something something
like that okay but maybe eight for a
three was to cover b4 movie night see
for coming aha so he puts all on dark
squares interesting then didn't really
expect this to happen trading the night
would would actually be nice now this is
the structure with that with a nitrate
would be nice but I don't see how to get
this in night to h4 is hardly possible
right to eat to be too maybe I to H
force may be coming at some point
yeah not really sure I'm not really sure
what to do by any way to get the night
train it 93 f five maybe night h4 I have
Luke g3i a maybe is preparing that yeah
so look here night at five is the idea
this is something that I can even play
with with the power structure damaged
it's not getting easily too okay he
wants to I have 92 down an ID to he
might have no it doesn't okay then
that's not a bad idea yep getting this
traded on 96 I can play a form i think
maybe not maybe not
f-for takes Knight takes this Bishop f6
and possibly Bishop to e5 okay but rook
f6 I have the shop g hive so there is no
no big problem here anything maybe 84
look G for work f6 now don't think that
this is so so bad yeah
I don't see a way forward of course I
don't want to retreat I don't know how
to five okay if I take taking us really
not a good idea okay okay now he's doing
something or try to do something now I'm
a bit down on the clock
it's nothing particularly scary though
I've seen I've seen worse now f6f six
and then 97 there how stupid is that I'm
just just killing my own Rukia ah and g6
is the whole look it's the whole rook
that was a super stupid move okay mm
that's frustrating I don't know how the
position was before probably not so
great but this is really completely
unnecessary now maybe the very close
nature of the position is helping me a
little bit
you know I'm attacking this rook it is
very closed that is a small help if to
get out of your check unfortunately my
night is this so badly placed time
morning
I mean ok I can still struggle here oh
no I really can see 5 + f6 Hanks
mmm check
two is six or to each other before is
just such a great square
I have no no active way really I can
just hold
trying to go to avo attacking a5 a4 is a
very strong square but the sisters of
course slightly risky word no risk no
fun check
496 check Isis he's covering that I
didn't see that check check check check
ah he let me back into the game and I
didn't do anything about it okay white
resemblance yeah I mean does this was
this was already good for wider does
this kind of position here I mean good
not probably not for not an advantage
but I mean losing is very difficult okay
I wanted but this this is I mean age
porn isn't just kind of good yeah white
is better here age 6 I it's still
difficult to do anything anything
substantial really okay okay this is an
idea evident that didn't see at all i
can pick up this pawn yeah well
ultimately i deserve to lose this i mean
really played it played it very badly oh
this was i know probably about okay but
this is such a this idea is so tupid
rook air-five yeah with what what move
can you expect yeah well f6 yeah and
then the rookies trip this is so so
ridiculous what i did here yeah i just
have to stay i mean it's it's it's just
very equal there's nothing nothing going
on rook air-five is just exceptionally
bad yeah okay
yeah i mean i couldn't i can still
somehow hang on for a while and not
loser immediately of course it helped
that he blundered shine under the porn
check but I 40 f4 is very strong I
didn't see that one yeah I'm not very
technically alert this is fantastic he
cannot take with any porn and yeah well
okay well we'll get five or so stupid it
deserves to lose it okay thanks for
watching